[Music]
in teacher confessions new it says my
confessions submitted by school for this
is school friends blue stealer magnet he
was working on magnum the entire time I
can only do blue steel deal I can only
do blues with your blue pants you got a
shot oh yeah right hello gosh
do it all of it and the socks oh yeah
yeah don't forget that socks the spikes
Lucille you can't nobody can I can't
turn to the left either high school
teachers share secrets they would never
tell their students oh yeah they talk a
lot of [ __ ] about their students you
guys know any high school teachers I
guess friends do they being in the break
room or something no [ __ ] this is a list
here it's titled high school teachers
are sharing their darkest secrets and
it's honestly kind of shocking okay it's
a BuzzFeed article honestly kind of
shocking good title all right so the
first one says yes I put you in a group
with the kid you have a crush on
intentionally I'm stuck here with you
180 days a year I want to see some drugs
oh yeah yeah that's so nice yeah
teachers do that I always guys so
excited when I got put in the same group
is someone I had a crush on yeah I did
for sure teachers were aware of that
Oh kids are so obvious virtually genies
boys and girls are so [ __ ] obvious
because it'd be like us watching kids
right yeah really so we do that [ __ ]
with a stare each other the whole time
looks like you know I'm saying like it's
like do they go like this oh yeah
touching but if they're not next to each
other all the way across the room there
like telegraphing the [ __ ] yeah damn bro
next one
your parents are literally the worst
part of my job I can see that I could
for sure see that parents are obsessed
with their kids these are just teachers
Oh general like it could be yet any
herons are super entitled with their
kids either parents are too interested
in their kitchens are not at all injured
my dad never went to mice me neither not
once but there were parents that were
obsessed with their kids that's my mom
she went all the time time she like sat
in a classroom with you my dad did too
yeah I was in first grade and I got I
was getting a lot of trouble so am i up
for one of the class periods my dad
pulled up a chair and he sat next to me
on my little [ __ ] guest bells like
two feet off the floor and I just felt
so embarrassed that I was the only
person with a parent that was like
laughing at me do my mouth full-blown
there was a school shooting like 3,000
miles away from us and she pulled my ass
out of school mr. Keeney Atacama and I'm
like why
and then they're like your mom's like
school shooting or something I'm like so
I'm the kid who's getting pulled out of
school because my mom is afraid of dream
come true no it sucks because everyone
knows that I'm that guy the word will
get around that when he comes back home
a little [ __ ] make fun of her I know
they always find out yeah exactly know
the people who came in to get you there
I'm like what's going on told me it's
your fault yeah so I forgot to mention
the whole reason why like the teacher
started doing these confessions it was
on Reddit and the thread asked what is
the one thing that you want your
students to know that you'd never tell
them in person so it's like an open
letter to your dancing yeah so the next
one the weed smell doesn't magically
disappear between the parking lot and my
classroom that one's an ocean and I'm
yeah I am stupid cuz I I just thought
because I was never called out for it it
didn't smell anymore
yeah so they must have smelled me in the
new Ella's house for sure is it legal
now for high school kids just like if
you were 21 you can't drink at work just
because it's legal to drink
you can drink at work we went to what
Google and they have beer on tap yeah
those are the cool offices though our
socials and [ __ ] yes next slide if your
parents email a teacher and argue with
them the whole staff knows oh I bet oh
I'm sure excellent we have much better
hearing than you assume we just choose
our battles as it pertains to
inappropriate comment I get it but I
want to hear the specific [ __ ] they
heard I know me too I want some stories
yeah I know these are all a team like
I'm laying in bed all day and I'm trying
to watch my stories and it's all pretty
no it's just the teasers of the story
yeah next one if I know your name by the
third day of a new school year that
means you're probably an [ __ ] or a
teacher's pet right why can't you
remember people's names dude my teacher
30 kids do a lot by the third day in my
middle school mr. car he wrecked he
memorized everyone's name after you told
it to him one time and he went around
our whole class in the first day of
school and pulls our name that's amazing
only five kids
it was [ __ ] crazy there's like a
magic [ __ ] parlor trick you do as you
associate their name with something on
them like like I'd be like just blue
eyes like I just remember just blue and
I've been like Dookie ask Jess yeah
whatever it is you see that's not even a
word see some people do like Dookie does
the same letters like like Jess they'll
have like a word that like just jar or
whatever the whole school knew my name
yeah like I'll like that and I'm like
[ __ ] climbing up that tetherball Pole
or some [ __ ] and some random teach I've
never seen before
mr. Kwan get down from there I'm like
did you ever get by follow me no oh
you pixie Geo
doofy Jess it should be Bartholomew I
completely disagree with partner I
disagree with it I disagree with mine
Stephen with the pH it's mmm that's real
bad my mom named my brother Stephen with
the pH and then he got it changed
immediately why what's wrong with
Stephane that's not we mediate because
you are always like Stefan
dude we went to like 17 hospitals during
the winter break and every time I have
to loosen up like Stefan step in Stefan
and then maybe randomly Stephen maybe we
should change
I know exactly did they do it like that
it's just to be pain in the ass so that
because you had to change your I know go
through that process you could have you
could have no wait never mind it's only
the middle name
this is like the 16 year old mothers who
spell like Jessica jess3 and her name it
was G es s ika
and it was so annoying every time I saw
her name like honor whatever work I
would just like and then there's actress
named just secret Nicole and it's like
just just Sica name is just Sica but
where's she from
I don't know my cousin is Nicole and I
CH oh oh oh yeah that was a popular over
to spell a spell but back then I had to
specify everyone would automatically
spell my name like that
really yeah the nick whole Nick oh you
don't spell then they call no it's just
oh you don't have the H no it's pretty
common anyway it was really common in
the 90s yeah just follow that way dude
Giovanna is a full names [ __ ] sick
thank you it's Giovanna Antoinette
that's sick as hell in Kwan don't forget
that Daniel the most important part
that's very classy man yo my name yeah I
didn't know that was the last water dope
ass last name
yo says I kept it shut up see I knew all
that [ __ ] I just did no barge was Barton
yeah I was pretty much the loser
yelling [ __ ] in the hallways doesn't
make you a badass
teachers are yelling [ __ ] their heads
all day long what about yelling penis in
the hallways in lunch it would be like
playing the penis game you start like
whispering it and then you get louder
and louder and their to be the loudest
get many like familiy be the loudest one
it's kind of like a dare like oh you're
gonna go higher this is an elementary
school or high school every [ __ ]
middle school like that's the worst age
I feel like it is because they know it
all they're not that young but they're
not old enough and they're like stuck in
this like [ __ ] they just hit puberty
you're the worst looking awkward great
and they're [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] that they've comedic ly matured
all the way which
it's just my favorite fact like I could
still be in a movie like six months ago
and here's some kid go penis before the
credits start you know and I [ __ ] about
this it's stupid
I laugh because he thinks that's [ __ ]
legendary dude that's why I love that
[ __ ] well I think he's been getting
funny or two but not liking a stupid
immature way cuz obviously you know
that's too bad he's not gonna give me
the good job crack me up because I was
telling Casey something and then Isaac
was being nosy so he was like oh mommy
what did you say I was like oh nothing
baby like you know you don't need to
know everything right he was like mommy
come on like you know me you know us you
know the way we are nobody said you know
me you know us you know the way we are
he's doing it like he's doing a movie
that's really good alright next one my
students are the reason why I'm
second-guessing having my own kid I can
see that a person doing wrong then
they're probably middle-aged [ __ ]
what is it [ __ ] middle school that's
what he's punk dude imagine having a
teenager like that's your kid right yeah
then you're at school and you have
twenty five teenagers an hour an hour
you can't really discipline them cuz
they're not your kids and by law you
have to like you only have this small
window of disciplinary action I'm no
thank you in all the way out of there
maybe that teacher should just smash
kids then no cuz then you have [ __ ] up
people that just want to smack kids cuz
they're [ __ ] up well true at the smack
around thirty thirty kids how come they
ruin it for the people who just want to
use it to correct kids the tale
shouldn't wake the dog to you I didn't
make the rules okay sure alright next
one I encouraged my worst kids as much
or more than my favorites because I
don't want them back in my class that's
a good teacher
wait you okay I don't want them back Wow
read that one it reminded me of what you
what you said Bart
really what how you had this one teacher
where you were just failing the hole
that you're just you were not doing good
in that class and then they were just
like listen man if you can just draw
this thing or write this thing I'll pass
you yeah I'm like without you
reminded me of did at your school did
you have registration where you had to
go to the school on a separate day and
then you signed up for the teachers and
you met them in person you sign up for
teacher yeah yeah we went to the teacher
this is high school yeah in high school
yeah open enrollment and you go and you
sign up for the teacher you want like
two at their table they're all sitting
in like a big round table at the
cafeteria and you go to each one and you
like and then you like sign up for their
class and then like it was all about the
group that you were in because sometimes
you go in there and that teacher
schedule was already filled and you
couldn't get that teacher okay so my
friend couldn't make it and he was a
year younger than me and his name was
Taylor so Taylor can be a girl or a boy
his name so I went for him and you also
take your school picture that day so I
took my picture instead of it was like
under his name and it was in the
yearbook he was like me and then I
signed up for all his classes and each
teacher they look at your card and then
they like they like tell you what they
think like if you can be in their class
or not and each teacher lectured me
they're like Taylor you gotta do better
this year
yeah god I do better than you did last
year this is not okay all right Jesus I
didn't know any of this about my friends
so like I'm a I was like a straight-a
student and I've never gotten lectured
by a teacher if you got a glimpse into
that life oh yeah like I didn't know it
was like that these teachers were like
come on man like you gotta do your
homework I'm proud about riding on your
friend and being like ha this isn't me
I'm so sorry yeah okay yeah you got it
no I'm really set this year you knew
your new me oh wait then what would you
do when it was you know I wouldn't twice
but I didn't sign up he was a year
younger so is different too what about
when he shows up for class and they're
like Taylor what the [ __ ] did you do to
your hair and body and penis remember
do babies do yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]